foreign
Millennials are leading the big quit in
so there was the great resignation now
there's the big quit yeah who's coming
up with these well it's it's headline
writers it's people on social media I
mean come on do I get to come up with
one at this point I feel like it's my
turn you know what why not mine is a
party every day is now a thing it's a
day National chip day National Best
Friend Day National Small Dog Day it
never it's just enough it's too much I
went on my Instagram account today at
Ken Coleman and I just looked at the
camera and said look if I hear quiet
quitting one more time I'm gonna go
headbutt an 18-wheeler it's all I hear I
can't do it anymore it was like during
covet it was unprecedented oh yeah
remember you got to Pivot yeah all right
boy you really do pay attention to
everything Dave says thank you yeah yeah
those are Dave's lines you stole those
There's No Stealing here we're all we're
all family it's like the Olive Garden
Ken all right so now why are we talking
about this headline uh this is a CNBC
article that I'm pulling from because
this affects you all some of you are in
this mindset
more than half of U.S workers
the number is actually 61 percent
are considering leaving their jobs in
2023.
this is from a new LinkedIn study
now it was interesting George that the
uh higher percentage or the highest
percentage of gen z
um uh workers are planning to call it
quit so of all of the generations gen Z
Millennials Gen X and Boomers it was gen
Z planning to call it quits
now the Millennials got beat up a lot uh
your generation about switching jobs uh
on a regular basis many Millennials this
data is probably about eight years old
but at that time Millennials were
thinking I'm going to stay about a year
on the job and then move on
um but this is what's interesting
Jen's ears
according to Karen Kimbrough the chief
Economist at LinkedIn they're more
passionate about finding a job that
aligns with their personal values
and they're confident that switching
jobs will help them get there
so the main reasons that gen ziers and
Millennials are considering switching
jobs hasn't changed with higher comp
improved work-life balance opportunities
for career growth and flexible work
range it's all ranking is top priorities
so again nothing new here you could say
the same about Millennials what is
different is that there is a sizable
shift from the older gen xers and the
Boomers
to the Millennials and the genzirs and
it is you know what
I want to do something that I connect to
um it's very personal
and I like that because that that's
helping people get in aligned with what
I'm trying to teach is that there is
purpose in work Beyond a paycheck and
this younger generation does long for a
connection uh in their work and I think
that is a good thing except that if you
make it all about well I'm only going to
work for a company that is very open
about their political views aligning
with mine that can get to a point where
you never it's like trying to find a
perfect Church good luck that church
shopping can be brutal here in Nashville
so thoughts on that you are a millennial
well there's a I think there's been a
cultural shift you see my parents
generation my grandparents generation it
was it was survival it was get an
education so you can get a good stable
job so you can get a pension and things
have shifted we are now in a society
that wants to thrive and so they're
going I actually want to enjoy the work
I do because I saw my parents go to work
for that paycheck and they hated that
job yeah and so they're going oh we
don't have to do that and so I like this
mentality of let me go find that thing
what I don't like is the anti-work group
or saying I don't think we should have
to work at all as a society this is
terrible I love it when they go this
ain't it let me go figure out what it is
now the only risk here and this is why
we highlight this so if you're a gen Zer
a parent of a gen Zer understand these
people are just looking up they're
paying attention to the environment
and since the middle or let's call it
third quarter of 2020 when this thing
called the Great resignation happened if
you don't know what that is don't worry
about it
but we've had
four plus million people each month for
18 consecutive months this is latest job
numbers out of November of 2022. folks
that is a staggering amount of people
that are quitting their jobs so for
those of you that are as old as me or
older you understand what musical chairs
was fun game that George has no idea
what it is so that's what the job market
looks like and these young people are
looking up and they're going hey I see
my friend move over here and they got an
eight percent bump or a 12 bump or
whatever and so now it's just like okay
now we're just going until the Music
Stops the question is when does the
music stop
and with a recession looming this year
how bad it is I don't know I tend to be
less alarmist I don't think it's going
to be big and bad but we'll see and so
the point here is is that our money
principles what we teach here
is that hey you know what sometimes it's
okay to stay
because moving for a bigger paycheck may
come back to bite you if it's an awful
environment or you're actually not
qualified to do the job or they lied to
you and now all of a sudden you're in a
situation where oh I may have to make
another move and I'm putting my
financial stability at risk there's no
reason for that
and so that's why it's budgeting the
baby steps can get you some more
patience oh yeah having some Financial
Foundation it helps you slow down and
make better decisions yeah all right now
let's go into another thing that's very
distressing for this young generation
America needs carpenters and plumbers
and more people in the trades
and employers are having a hard time
they got the need but they're having a
hard time finding them why
well the application rate for young
people seeking technical jobs like
Plumbing building electrical work George
has dropped by 49 in 2022 compared to
2020. that's only two years that's a
massive drop now I'm gonna tell you
something you're going Ken I why in the
world are you talking about plumbers and
electricians because
you want to know what makes a healthy
economy a strong Housing Industry you
can't have a strong Housing Industry if
you don't have Carpenters plumbers and
electricians
if you all going to sleep on this and
you think oh it doesn't matter you're
wrong
now these positions continue to grow the
need is there but students applying for
them is dropping here is a statement
from a spokesperson at the U.S Chamber
of Commerce for a long time our society
has not talked favorably about the
skilled trades they're right we've
instead encourage students to go to
college all of them go to four-year
institutions graduate and go into white
collar jobs now let me just throw
something out here George it's going to
feel a little negative but sometimes I
just have to tell the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
me God
remote work and hybrid work is the
biggest threat to White Collar jobs that
we've ever seen
do you know why thank you for asking
because it's not long before companies
are start to go wait a second you want
to make 120 or 150 to sit at home
and work
or work couple days a week
in the office and I can hire somebody in
India for 60 to do it
I'm gonna let that sit for a second
do you think I'm this soothsayer of
negativity I'm not I'm telling you
companies are doing studies on this now
and it is going to be a wake-up call and
it might be six months around the corner
if we hit a serious recession
companies start going I'm going to
Offshore your job
now I'm not anti-remote work some people
I I make comments like oh you're a no no
I'm not I'm just telling you it is a
risk well is there a higher chance of
being laid off yeah if you're a remote
worker are we seeing that in the data
yes absolutely out of sight out of mind
they're going to lay you off especially
if they're trying to pressure you to
come back in again I don't want to get
off track here but but I'm just pointing
out that the trades folks we we've got
this marketing message that's been
shoved down our throats
that the only way to be successful is to
get a college degree and yet we're
seeing the date of the degrees are
becoming less and less relevant at
Building Wealth I told you it's by 2023
trend of the year and Big Time companies
are are removing the requirement for
degree and yet we've got trades jobs
where a kid can go to a trade school
right out of high school for next to
nothing and come out making 50 60 Grand
do that for two or three years keep
moving up financially George and then
start their own business and create jobs
it's half of the time at a tenth of the
cost and you're making more on the other
end yes in other words it's capitalism
so you know what the real issue is you
parents out there for your kid who
doesn't want to darken the door of a
college because that's not how they're
wired why don't you get over yourself
and realize that it's about their
success not your status
get over it that'll preach